nous sommes aujourd'hui dans le cher à
vierzon ici des passionnés font revivre
une entreprise qui a vu le jour en 1847
disparu depuis la sv la société
française de vierzon et est spécialisée
dans l'entretien et la fabrication de
machines agricoles
cette association depuis 26 ans tente
d'entretenir ce patrimoine local
industriel
une découverte à suivre avec charles
mercier samuel foucault et marion dubois
au coeur du centre ville se cache un
trésor
plus de 350 engins agricoles fabriqués
ici dans les ateliers de la société
française de vierzon les plus anciennes
ont plus de cent trente ans jacques et
charmante ce lieu vit encore aujourd'hui
ça y est c'est fini
annoncé pendant grâce à une équipe de
passionnés à ce que tu remets la dynamo
pas formés pour la dynamo c'est un
alternateur mais la foule est plus
petite la cour est trop longue les
klingons roi sa chance tous les
vendredis après midi ils soudent vidange
et bichonnent à l'aide de leurs outils
et surtout de 8,2 coude c'est
rudimentaire
c'est le b à ba de la mécanique on sait
pas tout il ya des trucs qu'on devine
parce qu'il ya du savoir faire qui a
disparu 1 les gens qui ont fabriqué ces
engins là ils sont ils sont plus là pour
nous expliquer qu'il ya une rupture
entre le moment de s'arrêter puis
aujourd'hui
à une époque c'était complètement
délaissé cette fois là c'était même un
gars d'avoir un truc comme ça quand le
moteur démarre enfin les effluves
d'huiles d'essence et leçons viennent
vous chatouiller les narines et les
oreilles ces machines anciennes peuvent
paraître désuète de nos jours pourtant
elle renferme pour ces bénévoles odeurs
et le bruit de l'enfance pour michel
fils d'agriculteur c'est lors de son
adolescence qu'il a découvert l'univers
de ces engins à moteur mon père quand et
pour un coursier modernisé il avant il a
vendu un cheval il a acheté un tracteur
comme ça le même directeur que ça
d'occasions s'il y en avait sept heures
ce qui coûtait moins cher à l'époque moi
j'ai appris à conduire au dessus j'avais
14 ans c'est mon père il est passé du
cheval autres acteurs pour s'arrêter la
petite histoire c'est qui au lieu
d'appuyer sur les pédales de freins et
il disait aux autres acteurs jean on
peut parfois appuyé sur la de
frein si l'on doit pas s'arrêter
l'entretien de ses machines est aussi
une façon de ne pas voir sombrer dans
l'oubli ce savoir faire industriel et de
transmettre aux jeunes générations
c'est important que la mémoire de nos
anciens
persister qu'on puisse mettre ça à
disposition du jeune public
pourquoi pour ne pas perdre la mémoire
justement c'est pour ça que
l'association s'appelle la mémoire
industrielle et agricole pour ne pas la
perdre
[Musique]
et je suis avec caroline âgées qui est
guide ici au musée de vierzon alors on
voit il ya beaucoup de tracteurs autour
de nous l'industrie des machines
agricoles était un vrai poumon emploi
d'emplois ici à vierzon will use in
société française a compté jusqu'à mille
sept cent quarante personnes
nous étions parmi les cinq premiers
fournisseurs de machines agricoles en
france
lusine a compté jusqu'à mille sept cent
quarante personnes
donc ça commence très tôt ça commence en
1848 avec célestin gérard donc ça
s'appelait pas la société française au
départ et c'est lucie arbel ensuite qui
va racheter l'entreprise de ces destins
gérard et l' usine va se développer au
fur et à mesure des besoins jusqu'à
jusque dans les années 58 59 1958 1959
date à laquelle l'américain case va
racheter entrer dans le capital rachetés
lusine l usine perdurera jusqu'en 1995
mais à la fin donc on fabrique des
tractopelles matériels de travaux
publics
donc voilà c'est un ca se terminera
malheureusement jusqu'à la
délocalisation du site est alors dans ce
musée on peut voir aussi qu'il n'y avait
pas que les machines agricoles
ici à vierzon en termes d'industrie non
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de savoir
faire beaucoup de manufactures dont la
porcelaine la verrerie le grès la
faïence et la confection et on l'a vu
aussi à l'extérieur vous continuez à
réhabiliter ici à vierzon et à faire
vivre cette mémoire industrielle
oui le site continue d'être aménager
rénover la restauration a commencé en
fait après la fermeture de l'usiné en
1996 donc la façade par exemple a été
refaite en 2006 et voilà il ya une
tranche de travaux qui a débuté là bas
au bout
afin d'y installer d'y installer des
activités diverses et variées on
entretient cette mémoire et on avance
aussi avec voilà il faut prendre appui
sur ce qui a existé pour construire
vierzon le vierzon de demain c'est
vraiment faut il faut il faut comprendre
que cette passerelle est importante que
le passé fait aussi ce que ce que le
garçon sera demain merci pour cette
visite du patrimoine industriel de
vierzon quant à nous nous nous
retrouvons demain pour une nouvelle
découverte du patrimoine industriel en
région centre val de loire